PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, I'd like to take a
look at solving a linear ODE
but with a periodic input.
And specifically,
we're asked to find
one solution, a particular
solution, which is also
the periodic solution of
the differential equation
x dot dot plus 2x dot plus
4x equals the square wave
function.
So the square wave function
is a periodic function
with period 2pi.
It's defined as minus 1 and
1 on the intervals minus pi
to 0 and 0 to pi.
And we know that the
square wave function has
the following Fourier series.
So I'll let you think about
this problem for a moment.
And I'll come back in a second.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So the reason we've been
studying Fourier series
is to essentially solve
differential equations
with complicated forcing inputs
on the right-hand side which
are periodic.
And the reason we've been
studying Fourier series
is because we know that
differential equations
with sines and cosines
as forcing terms
on the right-hand side are
relatively easy to solve.
And we want to be able to
solve the same differential
equation with a more
complicated periodic function
on the right-hand side.
So the general approach
is to first decompose
the right-hand side
into a Fourier series.
And this step is essentially
already done for us.
We're told what the
Fourier series is.
And what we do is
we solve the ODE x
dot dot plus 2x dot plus 4x.
And I'm just going to take one
term of the Fourier series,
sine n*t.
So if we know the
right-hand side is
a sum of a whole bunch of
sines, what we're going to do
is we're going to solve for any
specific one of those sines.
So we want to solve this
differential equation.
And then, we use superposition.
So if we know what the
solution is to one sine n*t,
and we know that the right-hand
side forcing is a sum of many
sine n*t's with
appropriate weight factors,
then we can use superposition
to construct a final solution.
So this is the method
to attack this problem.
So we were given step one,
and we want to solve step two.
And we can solve this just
using the exponential response
formula.
So what we're going
to do is we're just
going to complexify
the right-hand side.
So if I want to solve the
differential equation x dot dot
plus 2x dot plus
4x equals sine n*t,
I'm going to denote the
solution with the subscript n.
And it's going to be
the imaginary part
of-- and I'm just using the
exponential response formula--
1 over the characteristic
polynomial evaluated at i*n,
e to the i*n*t.
You might ask how do I get that.
Well, I basically just took
the complexified equation,
and noted that sine n*t
was the imaginary part of e
to the i*n*t, and then used the
exponential response formula.
And I want to take the imaginary
part at the end of the day.
So what is the
characteristic polynomial?
In this case, it's s
squared plus 2s plus 4,
which means that p of i*n is
going to be negative n squared
plus 4-- so I'll just group
the real terms together--
plus 2i*n, so the 2i*n
comes from the 2s term.
And then x of n is going to be
the imaginary part of 1 over 4
minus n squared plus
2i*n e to the i*n*t.
And I'm going to use the
amplitude-phase form.
I'm going to convert this
Cartesian complex number
into an amplitude-phase
form just because it's
going to make taking the
imaginary part of the solution
very easy at the end of the day.
So the amplitude of this complex
number is 4 minus n squared,
quantity squared, plus the
imaginary part squared,
so that's 4n squared,
square rooted.
And then, upstairs is e^(i*n*t).
And downstairs, it's
going to be e^(i*phi).
And I'm going to put a
subscript n on the phi
just because for
each complex number,
we're going to have a
different phase phi.
And that phase
phi_n is going to be
the arctangent of 2n divided by
4 minus n squared, like that.
So now, I can combine phi of n
with the upstairs term, i*n*t,
in the exponent.
And when I take
the imaginary part,
I'm only going to be left
with sine of n*t minus phi_n.
So x of n is going to be 1 over
4 minus n squared squared plus
4n squared quantity
squared-- square rooted--
times sine of n*t minus phi_n,
where phi_n was given using
the arctangent formula.
And this gives us a
solution, which note
is periodic with period 2t--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
I should also note that phi
of n is between 0 and pi.
And this gives us this one
solution to the differential
equation with a forcing of sine
n*t on the right-hand side.
So now what we want to
do is we want sum up
many of these solutions using
the superposition principle.
So if I go back now,
I'm going to write
the original
differential equation.
So I'm just going to go
back and just rewrite this.
And I'm going to write the
right-hand side using its
Fourier series, 1 over n
sine n*t, where n is odd.
And this is the problem we
originally wanted to solve.
And essentially what we've done
is we've solved the problem
for each individual sine n*t.
So how do we get
the full solution?
Well, what we have to do is we
have to multiply the solution
for each sine n*t by a factor
of 4 divided by pi and 1 over n.
And then, we have to add
all of these solutions
up for all odd values of n.
So for example, x is just going
to be 4 over pi sum of n odd,
1 over n times the
solution to every sine n*t,
which we've already computed,
and I've denoted it as x sub n.
And x sub n is up here.
So if we want to be
explicit about it,
I'll write the whole thing out
as 4 over pi, n odd, 1 over 4
minus n squared,
quantity squared,
plus 4n squared, square rooted.
We also have a factor
of n out front.
We have a sine n*t minus phi_n.
So there's the final answer
for a particular solution
in its full glorious detail.
We can also check that
this particular solution
is periodic.
Note how each sine
n*t is periodic.
And each sine n*t has
period of at least 2pi.
So when we sum up a
whole bunch of functions
which all have a
period of at least 2pi,
the sum is also going to be
periodic function with at least
2pi.
And as a result, this gives us
the answer we're looking for.
Also, in addition, if we want
the full general solution
to the differential equation
to this particular solution,
we also have to add
the homogeneous piece.
So this concludes the problem.
And I'll just quickly recap.
When solving a
differential equation
with a periodic forcing
function on the right-hand side,
again, to iterate
the steps, you first
Fourier decompose
the right-hand side
into summation of
sines and cosines.
You then solve the differential
equation for sine n*t,
cosine n*t individually.
This gives you a
solution for each term
on the right-hand side of
the differential equation.
And then at the
end of the day, you
use superposition to sum
up all of the solutions.
And that gives you one
final big solution.
So I hope you
enjoy this problem.
And I'll see you next time.